[Musique]
tchéquie mialy son développement
commercial is un traitement chimique
innovant et breveté qui permet
d'améliorer la performance des tests
diagnostiques in vitro par exemple des
tests rapides tellement de l'être on a
tous utilisés durant l'accueil de 19 on
améliore la limite de détection de ces
tests cette technologie qu'on utilise
c'est un traitement chimique dont
breveté qui a été développé inventé par
mon associé claude noguès avec plus de
10 années de recherche au sein de la nes
cachant qui est maintenant le nes paris
saclay où est hébergée actuellement
keane alice
springs
c'était un peu la mecque des start up de
paris-saclay donc l'occasion de
rencontrer d'autres start-up innovantes
dans le domaine de la santé mais pas que
la possibilité aussi rond pour
rencontrer des industriels laboratoires
pharmaceutiques développeurs de tests
diagnostiques donc toujours intéressant
pour une start up on est entrain de
commercialiser notre technologie on
cherche aussi des partenaires donc
c'était pertinent de rencontrer nos
besoins industriels aussi l'opportunité
de rencontrer des investisseurs
intéressant pour nous parce qu'on est en
train de lever un tour d'amorçage pour
financer la mise à l'échelle de notre
technologie
puis c'était aussi gagner de la
visibilité ce qu'on a bien fait bien
réussi à faire en remportant le concours
de pitch dans le domaine santé avec des
très belles boîtes est également qui fit
cher y avait de la concurrence et puis
un joli jury avec ipsen servier des
fonds d'investissement donc ça ça a
permis
de gagner un peu en visibilité au niveau
national ce qui est le bienvenu dans une
période de levée de fonds et de début de
commercialisation
c'était naturel de s'installer à le nsrs
paris-saclay puisque encore une fois la
technologie et man 2 le n est sonné
juste à côté de l'ancien laboratoire de
claude donc ça il ya déjà des synergies
en termes de recherche et de danse et
technologique on a un contrat de
collaboration par exemple avec le ls le
cnrs aujourd'hui sur un de nos projets
en interne
et puis c'est également le la
possibilité d'avoir en partage des
instruments qui sont trop onéreux pour
un achat en interne qui m'ya l'iss puis
évidemment l'accès à tout un vivier de
plateformes sur lesquelles on peut avoir
accès à ces instruments d'étudiants et
de personnes en thèse qui travaillent
sur des sujets d'intérêt pour qu'ils n'y
alice donc c'est finalement un peu un
point central même si on est éloigné de
paris centre c'est quand même un point
central dans le domaine dans lequel on
évolue avec tous les industriels qui
sont déjà
présents sur le plateau des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques des développeurs
d'outils d'analysé in vitro donc c'est
ça fait énormément sens d'être présent
ici sur le plateau